these Fink's is a mythological creature
that featured in Greek Egyptian and
Persian legend and today it's the Greek
variation of the Sphinx that were going
to examine the actual physical
appearance of the Sphinx differs
drastically depending on region but in
Greek mythology it was most often
represented as a creature with upper
body of a woman the lower body of a
lioness with the wings of an eagle and a
serpent headed tail the Greek origin for
the word Sphinx was believed to have
derived from the word sphingo meaning to
squeeze or to tighten which refer to the
way a lioness would bite down on the
throat of her prey using strangulation
to eventually kill them if we go by the
works of the Greek scholar Hesiod he
believed that those only one Sphinx that
ever appeared in Greek mythology in some
accounts she was a daughter of the
two-headed hound authoress and the
mother of monsters echidna and in others
she was the child of echidna and - this
Fink's was indeed best known for asking
riddles and being the bringer of bad
luck and destruction the Greek Sphinx
was believed her resided in the ancient
city of Thebes or fevers as it was
pronounced in ancient Greece and anyone
who entered the city would be greeted at
the entrance by the Sphinx where she
would ask travelers a riddle if they
answered correctly she would grant them
safe passage but if they were wrong a
passage will be denied and they would be
extremely lucky to even survive the
encounter the riddle that became
synonymous with the Sphinx was which
creature has one voice and yet becomes
four-footed two footed and three footed
those who could not answer this riddle
will almost always strangled and
devoured the second riddle that the
Sphinx would ask well there are two
sisters one gives birth to the other and
she in turn gives birth to the first who
are the two sisters eventually the
regent of Thebes King Creon became so
distressed by the presence of the Sphinx
that he offered anyone who destroyed her
the throne to Thebes as well as his
sister as a wife so up stabbed Oedipus
the nephew of King Creon accepting the
challenge of his uncle bravely when he
stood before the Sphinx he was asked the
first riddle and after careful
consideration he answered which creature
has one voice and yet becomes four
footed and two footed and three footed
he depor supplied man who crawls on all
fours as a baby then walks on two feet
as an adult and using a stick in his old
age when the second riddle was asked he
once again answered correctly
day and night these things are so
distraught that she had been bested
twice that she jumped from the rock she
stood on and died in some variations of
the story when e de Poisson surd the
riddle correctly she instead chose to
devour herself when the French poet Jean
Cocteau retold the story of Oedipus his
version did differ a fair amount in his
version the Sphinx no longer wanted to
kill and therefore told he to push the
answer to the riddle knowing that when
he answered correctly she would have to
kill herself
this version ends of Oedipus making love
the Sphinx refusing to thank her for her
assistance and then watching her die now
if you thought the end to that version
is a bit messed up and weird the
original story ends of Oedipus returning
to Thebes becoming the king and marrying
Queenie Acosta who turns out to be his
mother but that's a story for another
time if you guys enjoyed today's video
and you have any thoughts on either pus
or the Sphinx then let me know in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained